hi i'm dan bahush i'm a researcher in
the perception
interaction group in microsoft research
in redmond
and my work focuses on multimodal and
physically situated
interaction basically the main question
that drives my research agenda
is how can we get machines to reason
more deeply about their surroundings
and participate in interactions with
people in the physical world
now today however in this webinar i'd
like to talk to you about
infrastructures and specifically i would
like to introduce you to platform for
situated intelligence
now this is an open source framework
we've developed recently at msr
that supports development and research
in multi-modal
integrative ai systems i'm going to
clarify in a second what exactly i mean
by these terms multimodal and integrity
of ai
and what is the actual scope of the
framework but before we get going
i would like to say that while i'm
giving this presentation
and two of my colleagues sean anders
then ashley feniello
will be joining me for the live qa
session that follows
this is a work of a broader team of
engineers and
researchers and i would like to list and
thank and acknowledge all of them
uh right at the start okay so platform
for situation intelligence
which we sometimes abbreviate as
backslash psi
and pronounce like the greek letter psi
is an open source framework
that simplifies development and research
in multi-modal
integrative ai systems these are systems
that
leverage different types of streaming
data such as audio and video and depth
information
and that integrate and coordinate
multiple types of ai technologies
to basically process this data in real
time
so a prototypical example in this space
might be a robot
that uses cameras and microphone arrays
to try to understand the world around it
and engage in an interaction
with coordinated speech-gaze gesture
with multiple people
to for instance give directions inside
the building
building a system like this obviously
requires a lot of
multi-modal audio visual processing and
leveraging different kinds of
ai technologies speech recognition
computer vision
dialogue models behavioral controllers
for gestures
so on and so forth now this system is at
one end of the complexity spectrum and
psy as a platform uh was developed in
part
um to support development for this kind
of rich multi-modal systems that do a
lot
of intensive processing you have many
different components
at the same time the scope and reach of
the framework is actually much broader
basically anytime you are dealing with
temporary streaming data
or if you need to bring together
multiple kinds of technologies
and especially if you're in a situation
where your latency constraint or where
acting in real time matters the
affordances that
psy provides can accelerate
development over the last
years we've seen a lot of fast progress
with
machine learning in a lot of perceptual
ai technologies however
building end-to-end useful systems of
this nature
is quite a daunting engineering task and
in part the problem lies with the fact
that the
fabrics and programming languages that
we use to build these systems
are missing important primitives and are
not really well attuned
um to this type of task so sci is a
platform
was developed to address these
challenges and
simplify development for this type of
systems whether they're you know social
robots interacting with groups of people
in public spaces
um intelligent buildings instrument in
meeting rooms
mixed and virtual reality systems all
the way to applications that use
kind of uh simpler smaller devices like
a raspberry pi or some iot sensor
but that still do stream processing
so now that hopefully we've clarified
the scope of the framework
let's uh talk about the outline of the
rest of the webinar
so i will start by introducing uh by
i'll start by discussing uh some of the
challenges with building this kind of
applications in a bit more
uh detail after that i want to give you
an overview of the main aspects of the
framework
to get you familiarized with some of
these principles and tools and
affordances
and for you to get a sense about whether
this would be something that might be
useful in your own work
following this overview we'll do a bit
more of a deeper dive into actual coding
i want to do a hands-on tutorial
and show you how you might write a first
application with this and again
we won't have a lot of time to go into
the detail but the idea is to
uh give you a feel for what programming
with psi is like
and for you to be able to understand
whether this might be
something useful uh again in your own
work
the tutorial will take about 30 minutes
at the end of that
i will give you more pointers to some
documentation and resources
and then i want to bring the
conversation more to how you might get
involved
as i mentioned before psi is an open
source framework and we're looking
forward to really
creating a community here and getting
more people engaged
to help us bring this to the next level
and at the very end we'll have a live q
a session okay so let's get started from
the challenges
well to a large degree many of the
challenges with building this system
stem from their multimodal
and integrative nature these systems
work with different types of streaming
data so
audio video depth lidar
post tracking results speech recognition
results so on and so forth
this data is generally streaming a
different bandwidth
and with different latencies and it's
typically processed in these complex
pipelines
that bring together many kinds of
components
uh built out of heterogeneous
technologies right you might have
anything in these pipelines from
um you know sensor specific device
drivers to
uh cloud services that induce a certain
amount of latency
uh to deep networks that run on gpus and
other kind of gpu processing
to application specific logic and code
and interaction with databases so on and
so forth
now these systems tend to be pretty
compute intensive
and they often need to operate under
latency constraints
and so performance considerations are
quite important
oftentimes you want the systems to
behave well under load or under latency
and
properties such as graceful degradation
of performance
are often a requirement now even if you
leave aside the challenges that stem
from the
sheer complexity that these systems have
and from the fact that they use these
heterogeneous components and they have
the stringent
performance requirements a number of
other challenges
arise from the fact that the programming
languages
and the fabrics that we use today are
missing an important set of
primitives are not well attuned to this
kind of applications
for instance notions such as time space
and uncertainty
are core in a lot of these systems yet
these are not
first order objects in any of our
programming languages today
and as a result a lot of time ends up
being spent
developing low level infrastructure
issues
take for instance time i've already
mentioned that these systems need to be
fast but being fast
is not enough coordination actually
requires being latency aware
often times these systems need to
perform data fusion where a component
needs to
integrate information coming from
different pathways
well to do this correctly and in a
reproducible manner the information
arriving on these different streams
needs to be paired according to when
those events happened in the world
not according to when they reach this
component because that might be affected
by latencies in the system and so on
and so in the absence of the right
primitives a lot of efforts
end up being being spent on building
this kind of infrastructure
and debugging low level issues rather
than on the task at hand
finally i argue that these applications
also have
a specific set of needs um when you when
it comes to
um debugging and data visualization and
analytics
uh which are not uh sufficiently
addressed by the development tools that
we have today
so for instance debugging these complex
concurrent applications with breakpoints
and printfs
is not really scaling is not really
effective
at the same time other aspects such as
data visualization the ability to
inspect
and visualize these data streams as they
flow through the application
and the ability to run queries and
perform data analytics
can significantly speed up the
development cycle
so psy as a platform was basically built
out of a desire to address these
challenges
and basically to provide the right kind
of infrastructure and tools and
components
to accelerate development for this kind
of multi-modal
integrative ai applications the main
goal of the framework
is to lower the engineering cost
basically
and foster more innovation and research
in this space
and we're open sourcing this framework
because we believe success in this space
really hinges
on building a community on
bringing together expertise and know-how
from different areas
and ultimately on building a thriving
ecosystem where we can leverage
each other's work the framework is
cross-platform
works both on windows and linux and it's
built
net standard so it's a managed framework
that
um retains the affordances of a managed
programming language like c-sharp
uh so things like manage memory and type
safety
and so on while aiming to address the
performance requirements that
these applications often have at a high
level
psy provides three kinds of affordances
the psi
runtime provides infrastructure for
working with multimodal
temporally streaming data and it
provides a
parallel coordinated computation
programming model
that simplifies writing applications and
components in this space
there's a set of tools that are centered
on data visualization
annotation and data processing and
analytics that
accelerate the development cycle and
finally the third part is an
ecosystem of components that wrap
different technologies
and allow you to quickly prototype and
foster reuse so over the next few slides
i'd like to give you a brief overview
of each of these areas and i'm going to
start by talking about how psi
applications look like and what are some
of the affordances that the site runtime
and low-level streaming infrastructure
provide
so psy applications basically are
pipelines or graphs of connected
components
that talk to each other via streams of
data
i have a fictitious pipeline here where
there's a microphone and a camera
let's say you're trying to detect uh who
out of many people in an image
is the one talking so you take the audio
from the microphone pass it through a
voice activity detector
that tells you that speech is happening
similarly the images from the camera
around let's say through a leap movement
detector
and then you try to put these two
signals together
to figure out who is talking who is the
speech source
now writing these kinds of applications
wiring components together
is very easy to do inside the code on
the left hand side
kind of illustrates this simple
fictitious example
it takes about one line of code to
create a new component
and one line of code to connect to
components together
now once you call the run method on the
pipeline
the site runtime actually takes charge
of executing the pipeline so it
schedules the components for execution
and it uh starts flowing messages on
on these temporal streams of data the
streaming infrastructure in psi has a
number of
very important properties first of all
strings in psi
are strongly typed right so they're
based on dot net generics you can stream
any type of data you are not constrained
into only using
certain specific data types and you get
things like type safety now more
importantly though
is the fact that time is really a first
order primitive a first order construct
in the site streaming infrastructure so
each of these messages that are flowing
through the streams
are timestamped not only with a creation
time which is when the component that
generated that message
created but also is something we refer
to as an originating time
this time is a sign of the source when
uh the message first enters the pipeline
so for instance when the camera
first sees an image or the image or when
the microphone
picks that particular bit of audio and
the important property here
is that this originating time is
automatically carried
forward throughout the pipeline as the
message goes downstream
which means that each of these
components can basically be latency
aware because they know
what the time is when they receive the
message and they have access to this
originating time information
so they can find out the latency of the
message and this latency awareness
throughout the entire graph enables a
number of important scenarios
one of the scenarios is synchronization
and data fusion
for instance this component here this
speech
source detector
knows that these two messages arrive at
this specific latencies
so as messages arrive it can buffer them
and pair them according to
when they happen in the world as opposed
to when they arrive at the component
in fact psy provides a large number of
primitives
that support this kind of
synchronization
and data fusion interpolation windowing
all these time related operations and
eliminate the need for the developer to
think about how this exactly needs to be
done how much things need to be buffered
how things are coordinating
rather the developer can just use this
primitive operations
and compose an application and focus on
the task at hand
another important property of the site
streaming infrastructure
is that data can be easily logged
logging is a very important
you know aspect in these applications a
core piece of functionality
and psy enables it in a very easy manner
you can just apply a dot write stream
operator on
any of these streams and send the data
to disk
the framework automatically generates
custom serialization code so you're not
bound into any specific types you can
basically log
most.net data types and the fact that
the timing information
is persisted together with the data
means that we can enable another
very important scenario which is
reproducible replay
so for instance you can eliminate the
sensors in an application
and resurface the streams from a
previously persisted store
and rerun your application in a
reproducible fashion
so you can tune the application turn
various knobs on the downstrip
components
and improve them to get the results that
you want
this kind of reproducible
experimentation is an important
accelerator
in this space there's a number of other
affordances that the psi runtime
provides
and i don't have time to go into all of
them in detail here
but just as a high level the runtime
just like the components
also has access to the latency
information so that opens up interesting
opportunities in terms of how the
runtime does scheduling
um to get pipeline parallelism
efficiency
and to maintain things running at steady
state
it also enables uh developers to control
uh how the application behaves under
load so for instance application writers
can specify
on which streams information may be
dropped and under which circumstances
and which of the messages can be dropped
and so on and so forth i
don't have time to go into detail into
all these aspects here but there's a lot
more documentation
on the github site where you guys can
learn more
about this now so far we've talked
from the perspective of an application
writer
uh often times when you develop psy
applications you hopefully will be able
to reuse off the shelf a large number of
components
but chances are you will also have to
write your own components that are
specific to your own application
the site framework makes writing
components also easy
so for instance if i want to write this
speech source detector
all i have to do is write a class for
this component
and implement two so-called receiver
methods
one for each incoming stream right so
when a message
arrives on this stream the
voice activity receiver method gets
called and similarly when a message
arrives from the
leap movement detector then the
respective method for receiving that
leave movement gets called
that's pretty much what it takes to
write a component and then from inside
the receivers you can post messages
downstream to send them out on the
component
output now the sign runtime provides a
couple of other important properties
here and one of them
is state protection what i mean by that
is that you can define your own state
variable like for instance
this time since the person last spoke
variable here
and you can touch this variable from
both receivers you can write to it and
read it from both receivers
without having to lock it or worry about
concurrency issues
when the site runtime schedules the
various components in the pipeline for
execution it tries to maximize pipeline
parallelism
so we will execute receivers of
different components in parallel or
multiple threads
but it will always ensure that the
receivers
of a given component are executed
exclusive with respect to each other so
this exclusivity is enforced
automatically by the runtime so you
don't have to worry
about concurrency you can program this
component as if you live in a single
threaded environment
even though when it's put in an
application and run as part of a
pipeline
it will run concurrently with many other
components
so this is a property that simplifies
component authoring
and it couples to another important
property which is isolated execution
whenever one of these receiver receives
one of these messages
it can actually modify it and edit it
and touch it and manipulate
it internally however it wishes because
if this message is being sent to a
number of other receivers at other
components who can also touch it
the site runtime automatically ensures
that everyone gets their own copy so
there's an
automatic cloning mechanism implemented
that
again insulates the component writer
from the intricacies of a concurrent
execution environment
finally another uh important property
here
is that you can easily hierarchically
compose
sub pipelines into higher level
components
and this type of hierarchical
composition of course helps with
encapsulation
and with keeping the code simple at the
top level
uh but the other important property here
is that when the runtime executes this
each of these individual components
still run as individual sub-components
so we still get
fine-grained pipeline parallelism from a
runtime standpoint
and so this programming model fosters in
some sense using a lot of small
different components that execute in
parallel and avoid some of the traps
of growing large monolithic components
so hopefully this has given you a sense
of what are some of the
uh main principles and affordances in
the size streaming infrastructure and
runtime
and with that i want to switch gears and
talk a bit about
tools well in the space of tools we've
put a lot of accent on data
visualization
specifically psy provides this
application
we refer to as platform or situating
intelligence studio
or in short site studio that enables
users to
easily visualize uh data from
uh collected by sci applications so you
can open
one of these stores that was persisted
by psi applications and with simple drag
and drop
operation create these complex
composited
layouts in this case i have a
visualization from a sample application
in which a user can point to various
objects in the room
and the machine tries to detect and
understand what these objects are
you can have timeline visualizers so
things like audio numerical stream
speech recognition results
at the bottom there there's a latency
visualizer you can have 2d visualizers
like
images overlaid with object detection
results histograms and so on
you can have 3d visualization so you can
easily look at sort of
point clouds rotate around the image
various visualize various kinds of other
3d objects like
track bodies and camera views and so on
and so forth
you can easily navigate over time and
you can inspect various values that
streams take
over time you can easily zoom in and out
and you can adjust
which region of the data you're viewing
there are a number of ways in which you
can navigate basically
uh in the data and the tool makes it
pretty easy you can also play back
sections of the data
and you can do that uh at the regular
real-time speed and listen to the audio
that
was recorded or you can play back things
at a faster speed or at a slower speed
if that's of interest now apart from
all this uh support for visualization
another important aspect here that the
tool provides is data annotation so here
someone's demonstrating actually
creating annotations for which objects
this person is actually pointing to this
is a very useful
affordance in a lot of these systems
when you're trying to
either generate annotations for machine
learning or maybe
to tune and understand the behavior of
your application
all of these visualizations can be done
offline based on data that was
previously pre-recorded
but also live as demonstrated here so
you can open the tool and connect to a
store that is being
actively written to by a live
application and the streams will show up
live and you'll see what's going on
moment by moment in the system
and you can even drop out of live mode
and
scrub through the data and then catch
back up with whatever
it is uh actually playing um the
framework also has support for working
with large data sets for instance here
someone demonstrates a data set with
multiple sessions
so as your system runs uh and you get
multiple sessions you can accumulate
this in a data set
and then you can do data processing for
instance uh here
we're running a batch processing task
for generating new acoustic features
and then the streams that get generated
from this batch processing task can be
visualized
in line with everything else finally in
the long run we're planning to
develop fully interactive capabilities
here where you can write
short snippets of code and directly
interact with and manipulate with your
data
from code and see it as you uh write in
a re-evaluate um
print kind of loop so hopefully this
gives you a sense of the
data visualization and annotation tools
that are currently available
in the framework and with that i'm going
to switch gears to components
the components currently available in
the github repo
focus a lot on multi-modal sensing and
processing so
there's a number of components there for
sensors so like
cameras and microphones and other kinds
of sensors like
the azure kinect or intel realsense
there's components for processing
audio and imaging data and there's
components for doing things like speech
and vision and language processing
there's also components for running
machine learned models for instance
onyx dipnets and also
wrapping a variety of cloud services
azure cognitive services
the idea here is that we are providing
the seeds behind what we hope to be
a growing ecosystem of components i
think success
uh happens here when we're able to
leverage
each other's work so we're hoping more
of you
will get engaged and contribute your own
components in this space
the other thing i would like to say here
is that
while psy is an open source framework
it's not just open source it's really
meant to be an
open and extendable framework and to
interoperate easily with other kinds of
ecosystems so for instance ross is a
framework that's
very frequently used in the robotics
community and provides a number of
important affordances
well psych can easily bridge to ross and
it's possible to create hybrid systems
uh
for instance imagine a social robot
where navigation
is done via ros nodes and components
whereas the social processing part of it
is done with psi components
the framework interoperates with many
other ecosystems
you can use zero mq as a transport and
various kinds of data formats
uh to interoperate with things like
python and javascript and unity and so
on and
we continue to evolve this again the
core idea is that the framework is
meant to be open and extendable
so this brings me basically to the end
of the framework overview hopefully this
has given you a sense of
what are some of the main capabilities
in the framework some of the main tools
and whether this is something that might
be useful and interesting in your own
work
so next to make it all a bit more
concrete we're going to go in this
hands-on tutorial where i'd like to show
you
uh how to code the first sci application
so as an example we're going to build a
voice activity detector
it's going to be a very simple one we're
going to take a rather naive simple
approach but the goal here is just to
illustrate
how programming with psy works like so a
voice activity detector basically
determines when
in an audio signal there is speech or
not
and to do this we're going to start by
using a microphone component
we're going to capture audio with that
component and then we're going to pass
this audio
to another site component that does
acoustic feature extract extraction
now this component generates a number of
different features
and we're going to look at one feature
that's called log energy that kind of
reflects the amount of energy in the
signal so the more
noise there is if someone is talking the
energy will be high and otherwise it
will be low
so we're going to just try to threshold
this signal to recover basically the
blue signal the blue binary signal
that's the voice activity detection
signal and we'll do a
bit of more processing on it but that's
the basic idea
now this is a very kind of naive way to
build a voice activity detector
but it will be sufficient uh to
demonstrate some of the capabilities of
the framework
and once we do that uh just so that
i really showcase the fact that you can
build
uh rather more sophisticated
applications and can quickly prototype
something that's
much more complex and that does bring
together many different kind of ai
technologies
i want to very briefly in a couple of
minutes talk about this other sample
application written a couple hundred
lines of code
where a person can point to object in a
room and say what is that
and the computer tries to determine
which object is being pointed to
sends the cropped image to an object
detection service
and tries to understand basically what
the object is that the person is
pointing to
okay so let's get started i'll be using
visual studio
2019 professional edition but you can
also use the community edition
or vs code which also works on linux or
for that matter
any editor of your choice i'm going to
start by creating a new project
and this is going to be a c-sharp
project consoleapp.net course i'm going
to hit
next here and then i'm going to call it
a simple voice activity
as i hit create visual studio will take
a couple of seconds and generate a
basic project structure for us
now there are basically two ways in
which you could start coding a psy
application
one approach is to use the size source
code i've already mentioned
size available on github so you can go
to github.com
microsoft sci and clone the repo you can
then build a solution where you link
your application against the size source
code
and build it all together the second
approach which is what i'm going to use
here is to use nougat packages these are
binary packages that we provide with
every release and that speed up
development
as you don't actually have to build a
psi code base in this case
you just link against these packages and
this is an easier path
if you don't plan on actually modifying
the site code base
so i'm going to do that here and to add
these nugets you go to dependencies
right click manage nuget packages you'll
have to make sure that this
include prerelease check box is marked
because the
synonym get packages are still in beta
pre-release mode
and then i'm going to go to browse and
the first package i'm going to look for
is called microsoft.psy.runtime
this package contains most of the core
bits for the site infrastructure
so you'll use it in all your site
applications i'm going to hit install
it brings out a number of dependencies
and then i'm going to accept this
license
and the package gets installed now since
in this sample we'll be doing some work
with audio the other package i want to
install is called
microsoft.psy.audio.windows
this package provides windows specific
apis and components for things like
microphone capture audio processing
acoustic feature extraction and so on so
i'm going to install this one as well
now at this point you may be wondering
how do i know which packages do i
actually need to install when i write
the psi application
and this is where i'd like to point you
to our documentation
so our documentation is at our website
on github.com
microsoft slash psi and is accessible
via the wiki
now on the right hand side here there's
a sidebar with a lot of pointers to
various parts of the documentation
and we'll go through some of this in a
bit uh
more detail later but for now i just
want to point you to these two pages the
first one is a list of nougat packages
and the second one is a list of
components
the list of nougat packages shows you
all the different packages that are
currently available together with a
brief description
about what functionality they provide as
well as information about whether the
package is running on linux or windows
and what kind of cpu platform the
package is built for
on the list of components you can find
more detailed information about all the
components that are available
they're grouped under different
categories like sensors and imaging and
vision and so on
and there's information about which
package each component
is provided in and also a brief
description about what the component
does and information about the platform
so these two pages the list of nuget
packages and list of components
can be very useful in the early stages
when you're trying to discover basically
what's available
but let's now get back to actually
writing the application
i'm going to start by adding a couple of
using statements that will give us
access to the packages we just added so
using microsoft.cy
and using microsoft dot psi dot audio
now as we've previously discussed sci
applications consist of pipelines of
components connected to each other via
streams of data
so the first thing we'll have to do is
create the pipeline
this can be done easily by means of a
factory method called pipeline.create
which you can invoke to get back this
pipeline object
and to run it you can simply call the
run method on the pipeline
but in this particular case i'm actually
going to call this a sync version of the
run method
because what i want to have happen here
is i want to start the pipeline running
then i want to wait until the user
presses a key
and once the user presses a key i want
to actually stop this pipeline and
inside to stop a pipeline you have to
call pipeline.dispose
so this is pretty much all the code you
have to write in order to create
and run a pipeline now of course this
pipeline is at this point
empty it has no components in it so
let's start next to add some of these
components
and just so that you don't have to wait
for me to type from now on i'm going to
try to directly paste some code blocks
that i've written
and we'll discuss them line by line
so these three lines of code basically
create a microphone an acoustic feature
extractor and connect the two together
the first line creates the microphone by
simply creating a new instance of this
audio capture component class
every time you instantiate a component
inside you have to pass it the pipeline
object
and in this particular case i'm also
passing a configuration parameter to
specify that i would like this audio
capture component to generate
um audio in this specific format
similarly the second line creates an
acoustic feature extractor by
instantiating the corresponding
component and passing the pipeline
object and finally the third line
connects the two together
by using this type ii operator now in
general
inside each component has a number of
outputs or so-called emitters that
produce streams of data
and a number of inputs or so-called
receivers which receive the streams of
data and the pipe2 operator can connect
emitters to receivers
in this case the microphone component
happens to have a single output called
dot
out and the acoustic feature extractor
has a single input called dot in
so normally this code should look like
this
i am piping an actual emitter called out
to the receiver on this other component
called in
however since these two components have
a single
receiver and on this side a single
emitter the pipe to operator works
directly over them
allowing the code to be simpler and more
readable
so this is pretty much how easy it is to
create
and instantiate new components and
connect them together inside
now before i run this i want to do one
more thing which is to add some printing
information in the console
so we actually see something happening
as we run this little sample
remember that we're interested in
setting a threshold on the log energy
feature from the acoustic feature
extractor
so here are a couple of lines that
actually print that information
so from the acoustic features extractor
component
i take this log energy stream and to it
i apply
this stream operator called do that
allows me to specify an action to be
performed for every message on the
incoming stream
and the action in this case is specified
by this delegate
provided here that basically instructs
the operator
to print every incoming log energy value
to the console
now this pattern of applying operators
to stream
is quite common inside and we'll see a
couple more examples shortly but for now
let's just run this
so what we can see is that the log
energy values get displayed
and you can kind of tell that the values
are low if i stay silent
and then go higher if i start talking
so let's stop this you've noticed
probably that the print
printouts come pretty fast and that's
because
this do operator executes on the cadence
of the incoming messages from the log
energy stream
which in turn is generated by this
acoustic feature extractor component in
response to messages from the microphone
component
and this one generates audio buffers on
a fairly fast pace i think every 10
milliseconds or so
so what i want to do is slow that down
and the way i will do it is by
injecting a stream operator here in
front of the do operator
and this is the sample operator so i'm
going to sample this whole log energy
stream
on a specified cadence say about every
0.2 seconds
and that way the next do operator will
only work over these more sparsely
sampled messages
now when i run this again
we will notice that the cadence of the
printout has slowed down so now we can
more clearly read it and see that the
values are relatively high
when i'm talking and lower when i'm not
okay so the next thing i'd like to show
you is how to actually persist strings
to disk and how to visualize them
data logging is key in a lot of these
applications and psy makes that very
easy
the first thing you'll have to do is to
create a store in which to log this
information and
inside you can do this again with the
factory method call scisstor.create
and i'm telling you the name of the
store and the path where to put the
store on disk
and then to write these streams to disk
you simply use this other stream
operator called
write so here's three lines that are
writing the microphone stream
and two streams from the acoustic
feature extractor the log energy and the
zero crossing rate
to the actual store i have to specify
names for each of these
streams so this stream i'm writing it
under the name audio this one is log
energy and the third one
is called zero crossing rate
so when i run this again
you'll behave just like before only that
now the streams are actually written to
disk
testing one two three testing one two
three
testing one two three
so if we go now to the temp folder you
notice here there's a
simple voiceactivity.000 folder that was
created and
here there are a couple of files that
all together form the store
in which we have persisted these streams
the persistent system in psi is
optimized for throughput
and you might see multiple data files in
a store like this plus some
index and catalog files now we will be
able to actually visualize this data
and to do so we will use size studio
this is a tool that comes with a site
framework
you'll have to build it actually from
the site code base i've already done
that build so i'm going to just go ahead
and open it
the site studio is an app that lets you
visualize multi-modal data
you can open the store that we just
created in the temp folder
and you can pick any of these files our
studio figures out that all together
they form a store so you can select any
of them and open it
and the tool will display the streams
available in that store audio log energy
and zero crossing rate
you can visualize these streams by
dragging them in the visualization
container in the center so here's the
audio
here's the log energy and i'm going to
drag the zero crossing rate and overlay
it here with the log energy
now size studio lets you construct
fairly complex visualization layouts
with multiple panels and overlaid
visualizers and the structure of these
layouts is displayed in this tab
here so we see we have two timeline
panels
one contains a visualizer for audio and
the other one contains two overline
overlaid visualizers for log energy and
zero crossing rate
the panel on the right hand side shows
properties for
visualizers panels and streams so
here if i select zero crossing rate i
see the properties of this visualizer
and i can actually change colors and
various other aspects so for instance
here
i'm going to change this to a darker
color because we're less interested in
the zero crossing rate
then i'm going to select log energy and
i'm going to change this to a
brighter orange color and maybe increase
a bit the line width
size studio lets you also very easily
navigate over the data
you can actually zoom in with the mouse
scroll wheel and zoom out
and you can click inside this panel and
drag the timeline to the left or to the
right
at the top there's a navigation bar that
provides some more information about
timing
the entire black region at the top
represents the entire store
and this gray highlighted portion of it
represents the portion that's currently
in view and i can
select that and move it around so i can
move the view
across my store and i can also adjust
its edges
to basically adjust the portion of the
data that i'm actually seeing
you can also select portions of the data
and play them back testing one two three
testing one two three and actually you
can do that
at different speeds for now i'm actually
going to remove this selection
and zoom back to the level of the entire
store
what we'd like to do here is figure out
what threshold we should pick for this
orange stream to construct our voice
activity detector
and so we'd like to inspect some of
these values and you can do so by right
clicking here
and then selecting show legend which
will display sort of a live legend that
as you move your cursor over time
you will update those values so you can
see that high values are in the range
around you know
10 um and so on and low values are
around one
so for now let's just pick something in
the middle let's say
seven let's go back to the code
now to create this voice activity stream
i'm gonna actually use another stream
operator called select that allows me to
transform a stream by applying a
function
the function i've specified here is one
that returns true
if the log energy is greater than 7. the
resulting stream will be a stream of
boolean values
and i'm writing that to the store as
well under the name bad
now before we go and run this i want to
show you another feature of the
framework
oftentimes when you build an application
you may collect data from various
sensors like i've done here with the
microphone
but then as you tune the application
instead of running it live again
what you'd instead like to do is rerun
it over the same data
that you just collected perhaps many
times in a row
adjust and tune parameters and see how
the application responds
and how you need to tune the parameters
to get the behavior you want
so let's do that here instead of running
it live again
let's run it over the store we just
collected
so in the original application the audio
data was coming live from this audio
capture component so i'm going to remove
this line
and i'm going to create that microphone
stream instead
by opening a store and
opening the stream from that store to
open the store i just use the site
store.open method
and i pass in again the pipeline the
name of the store
and the actual path where the store has
been written
and to open the microphone stream i call
this openstream method on the input
store
i tell it the name of the stream which
in this case is audio and the type
of messages in that stream which is
audio buffer
everything else stays the same but now
when i run this application the data no
longer comes
from the live microphone but actually
from the store that we collected
a few minutes ago
now of course this story is finite and
at some point the stream of data will
terminate there it is i'm going to hit a
key again
and dispose the pipeline now a new store
was just generated so we can go ahead
and visualize that
inside studio if i go to open now
and go basically in the folder above
there's a new session that was generated
called zero zero zero one so if i open
this store
basically this will look the same
because those streams have the same
values
but now we have an extra stream here
called voice activity detector so let me
visualize this
well it kind of worked in general it
seems to be doing the right thing
except that we have these little
fluctuations up and down
and this happens because there's a lot
of variance in the log energy stream
and goes up and down pretty fast and
often there's internal
small internal sort of dips or silences
which we'll need to filter out so
basically instead of
switching from zero to one and from one
to zero
every time uh the log energy passes that
threshold we have chosen
we want to move from zero to one only
when the energy has stayed at one for a
while and similarly
from one we want to drop to zero only if
the
energy stays below the threshold for a
while now in order to determine
how long that should be we need to get a
rough estimate of what's the length
of these drops so i'm going to zoom into
one of these
and actually size studio does have some
tools that let you better understand the
measure
time if you click these three clock
buttons on the toolbar
the navigator displays some additional
timing information and now if i go and
select a region
then i can see for instance here what is
where is the selection end
relative to the selection start so where
is the red line
in this case relative to the green line
to the selection start
and that is in this case you know about
177 milliseconds
wide so that's the width of this
interval and just to be safe i'm going
to choose a larger value
say around 300 milliseconds so let's go
back to the code now
i'm going to paste another couple of
lines here to create basically this
filtered signal
um and we'll take the a look at them in
a second
actually i have a couple of small errors
here because i am using some link
operator so i'll have to
go to the top and add another using
clause for system.link
now if you look back here these errors
should have gone away
yes so here i'm using a couple of
additional
stream operators the first one is called
window and this lets me buffer a window
of messages
and in this case i'm looking for
messages
in a future interval of 300 milliseconds
the second operator is an aggregate
operator that lets me implement a
stateful computation
over its input which in this case is
this window of messages
when using this operator i have to
specify the initial value
for the state of the vad signal that i
want to produce
which is false at the beginning and then
i have to provide a function this
function has actually two parameters the
first parameter describes the previous
value of the vad computation as i've
said this will be a stateful
computation and the second is the buffer
of messages that arrives
as an input to this operator and this
function
actually constructs the signal basically
what this expression does
is it says that if the previous state
was false
then all the messages in the buffer
window have to be above seven
in order for us to return true and
alternatively
if the previous state of the vad signal
was already true
then we can remain a true only if it is
not the case
that all the messages in the buffer are
below seven
in that case when all messages in the
buffer are below seven we need to return
false
and then we're writing this stream to
the store as well
so let's run this one more time and
remember that we're still running over
the data that we've previously persisted
from the store that we collected before
only that now we're computing this
additional filter voice activity
detection signal
so let's go back to size studio now i'm
going to zoom out again all the way to
the session
and i'm going to open the new store that
was created one folder up here
and so now we have this vid filtered
signal so let's look at this one
okay so this looks better you can tell
it's not actually quite perfect like
we're still missing some regions here
but as i've mentioned already this is a
very simplistic way to build a voice
activity detector
it actually gets quite a bit more
complicated if you want to build
something that's really robust and
reliable
the reason i've shown you though this
small example is mostly to give you a
sense of what
programming with psy is like and about
the visualization tools that you can use
and how you can iterate and save data to
disk and replay from disk
to fine-tune an application
now looking back at code as you've seen
you can easily construct components
and connect them to each other with this
pipe two operator
and there are many other operators that
are available that let you process and
manipulate streams of data we've already
seen some of them like sample and do and
select and window and aggregate
there are many other important
affordances in the framework for
instance the framework has operators
that deal with temporal synchronization
and data fusion
or there are ways in which you can
control how the application keeps
up under load for instance you can
configure whether
when and which stream messages get
dropped if there are not enough
computation resources available
components can be organized and
aggregated hierarchically into sub
pipelines and so on and so forth
i will actually point you in a second to
more resources for learning about the
various aspects of the framework
now this example we've worked on has
been quite simple and so before we're
done here
i wanted to just briefly show you
another example that's a bit more
sophisticated
just to highlight how quickly you can
construct more complex multi-modal
integrative ai applications and i want
to start by showing you this in size
studio
now this store was collected with an
application we're trying to determine
what object a person is pointing to
let me take out this timing information
and open the new store
now as i've opened this store you'll
notice that because the store doesn't
contain any of these streams they appear
here with this yellow exclamation mark
icon
that indicates they're not currently
available basically in this store
they're in this unbound state
inside studio you can actually save and
reuse various layouts you've constructed
and in this case i've previously saved
the layout that's specific to this new
application
and to load it i can simply select it
from this drop down list
now as you can tell this is a somewhat
more complex visualization layout than
what we've worked with so far
now in this application we have an azure
kinect camera that's looking
into a scene here you can see the point
cloud visualized and this is a 3d
visualizer you can rotate around it
and we are doing body tracking and
determining the direction that the
person is pointing
we're intersecting that direction of
pointing with the depth map
and we're taking this point and
projecting it
back into the rgb color camera and
cropping a region around it
that's the image you see over here and
this image is being sent to
azure computer vision service to perform
object detection the results from object
detection are overlaid over the image
finally we're also using an audio
capture component
and voice activity detection and we're
cropping the audio in those regions
and sending it to azure speech
recognition which gets us back
speech recognition results the idea
being here that
a person could point to an object and
say what is that
and the machine would figure out uh what
they're pointing to and respond
and respond accordingly
now obviously an application like this
is processing a variety of data streams
including depth images and audio and
we've glued here
many different components from azure
connect to custom written gesture
detection code
we determine for instance when the
person is lifting their hand
this white signal indicates that and
only crop the region and try to figure
out the target
at those moments and we integrate this
with cloud object detection and speech
recognition
psi enables you to write such
multi-modal applications that leverage
many i
components very quickly and in a very
compact manner
and let me just really quickly give you
a peek at the code for this application
the patterns in the code are quite
similar we're creating a pipeline and a
store to write the streams to
we're instantiating audio capture
component and in this case for instance
azure connect component that will
provide streams for
images and tracked bodies and so forth
and we're doing um stream computations
via a number of stream operators
one of the patterns that i wanted to
quickly show you here is that you can
write
actually your own stream operators
bodies here is a stream of bodies
produced by the azure kinect camera
and this get closest body is a custom
stream operator that i just wrote for
this specific application
we've seen so far how psy has a large
number of operators that are generic
that operates over
that operate over generic data types
you can implement your own operators for
instance this one
is implemented over here and you
implement them as an extension method
for a particular kind of stream so every
time i have a stream that contains a
list of azure connect bodies
i can apply this operator and the code
of the operator is relatively compact
but it can be used as one line which
makes this readable
here at the top level and basically down
below
we do uh some other computations with
the streams we instantiate the
object recognizer and provided the azure
subscription key
uh and similarly with the speech
recognizer basically this whole
application
up to instantiating and running the
pipeline is pretty much at the top level
100 lines of code now there's these
stream operators that i've just
described that add maybe another 100
lines of code or so
but as you can see this application can
be written in a very very compact
manner
so hopefully between this example and
the one we worked through in more detail
before
this is giving you at least an initial
sense of what working with psi is like
now we didn't have time here to go into
a lot of detail
and there's actually quite a bit more
information available on the website
so next i'd like to point you to some of
that and orient you a bit around our
documentation
and resources
so as i've mentioned before our
documentation is accessible
from the github project wiki pages
and the sidebar on the right hand side
guides you through it
there's information about how to use and
build the framework
either how to build new applications
with nuget packages or how to actually
build the entire code base
and if you want to get started the best
place to
start is the brief introduction tutorial
now this tutorial covers some of the
topics we've already covered but at the
same time goes in a bit more depth and
also talks about other topics for
instance
synchronization and provides a number of
pointers
to additional readings and documentation
on various topics that are relevant so
it acts basically as an entry point
in the framework and you can go through
it at your own pace
following this i would recommend going
either through some of the samples or
through the tutorials
we have a number of samples and they're
described here
so there's a brief description with
information about whether the sample
runs on windows or linux
and also some of these samples have
walkthroughs
so more documentation about how the
sample was actually constructed and
again these pieces of documentation
point you to additional information and
link
into additional topics that you can
explore in more depth to learn about the
site framework
going back to the wiki the tutorials are
also a good place to start reading
as they provide a bit more of an
in-depth overview
of certain areas of the framework so for
instance i would definitely recommend
reading the tutorial on basic stream
operators
which explain the family of operators
provided by psy
the tutorial on writing components that
explains how to write new components
i haven't shown you any of that here in
other tutorials for instance
understanding how the pipeline actually
gets executed or
delivery policies which control the flow
of messages and permit you to drop
messages
when the application may not be able to
keep up
there's other topics on stream fusion
and synchronization
merging interpolation and so on so feel
free to produce all of these documents
they provide useful information
about how to use the framework there's
also documentation for a number of more
specialized areas under
other topics so for instance how to do
remoting site supports
constructing systems that are
distributed that talk to each other
across machines
or how to bridge to other ecosystems
like python or javascript or ros
and there's a number of other more
specialized topics
that are of interest to probably a
certain population of developers
in general there's quite a bit of
information on the wiki we'll continue
to add more documentation
and organize it in a way that's
approachable but also if you feel
there's a part of the documentation
that's perhaps
underdeveloped or you don't know how to
do something don't hesitate to just file
an issue on the github site
label it with documentation tag and say
hey can you guys document this part more
and so on so i think this brings me uh
to the end of
this brief uh dive into how to program
with psy
and let's go back to the slides
so hopefully this coding session has
given you a more concrete feel for what
working with psy
is like i hope you're also be able to
tell whether something
decides something that's interesting uh
for your own work
uh at this point uh and i'd like to talk
a little bit about
uh how you might get involved if you
choose to do so
uh so psy is built as an open source
framework and we are looking
for uh growing community around it
and finding more contributors that can
help us
push this to the next level so what are
the various ways
in which you might contribute well of
course use it
and let us know what you how you use it
and what you find
don't hesitate to report any issues you
find or bugs
if you think some feature important
feature is missing
or some documentation is missing also
don't hesitate to file issues on that
we welcome contributions of many
different kinds from finding bugs and
filing issues all the way to writing new
features
and especially developing new components
success i think comes only in this space
if we're able to leverage as i said
before each other's work
so we're looking to grow the component
ecosystem a number of
our early adopters have already started
building their own components and that's
great to hear would like to see more of
that uh going on
and ultimately if you find it useful
tell others about it
um we'd like to spread the word and with
that
uh thank you so much for listening to
this presentation
and we're ready to go to the live q a
session
hi everyone um thanks again for uh
tuning in to the
webinar on platform for city
intelligence and to the live
qa session that we're starting now uh
i know there were a little bit of
trouble at the beginning i apologize for
that there were some technical
difficulties with the logins you might
have missed the first few minutes of the
presentation
but it will be available also on demand
um
after the fact probably in a couple of
days or so um
so you can go revisit that if you need
to
uh i hope this you found the
presentation informative and um
as i mentioned at the start two of my
colleagues uh sean and ashley are
joining me for this live qa session
and before we start i let them briefly
introduce themselves
sean hey everyone i'm sean anders
i'm a researcher in the group working on
psy
and ashley and hey everybody i'm uh
ashley i'm one of the engineers
also in the research group working on
psy
cool um so uh before we dive into
some of the questions there are a lot of
great questions thank you so much for
for
all the questions you guys have sent
we've tried to answer some of them on
the spot and
we will address some other ones right
now before we
uh we do that i just wanted to mention
that since we recorded the webinar
we also pushed out a new release and um
a couple of you were asking about the
what is that sample that was
demonstrated and whether that's
available
and i wanted to say that um that we are
shortly going to make that available in
the
samples report together with the both
examples actually that we work through
in the coding part of the webinar will
become available um
and just keep an eye on the repo and
you'll see those
those updates uh we're also working on
longer kind of archive paper that
describes the framework in more detail
that can be a good resource for those of
you that are interested to take a sort
of a more in-depth look
into the um inner aspects of how the
framework is built
so stay tuned we'll post that
information on the repo
um and now let's go to the to the q a
and here i
i wanted to start with um like i said we
got a lot of really good questions i
want to start with a question that we we
actually often receive that are arrived
here but we also received in other
places which is
uh what's the relationship between psy
and ross how the site relate to ross
and how does it relate to can i program
sci for instance with python or other
ecosystems
and um i'll let ashley say a few more
things about this
okay yes this is a question we get a lot
some people ask whether there are
language bindings for
non-dotnet languages for psy and there
isn't exactly language bindings for
doing
psi like things in other languages but
we can communicate with
other languages such as python
such as javascript and node.js etc
the way that we do it is through an
inter-process communication mechanism
inside of microsoft.site.interop is a
bunch of libraries and tools for doing
this
we can encode side messages to
more ubiquitously available formats such
as messagepack or json or
csv or you can bring your own format
it's an extensible system
and then we can transport those over a
message queue 0mq there's libraries for
that
for python and for javascript
and in that way you can bridge between a
sci application running in one process
and say a python application running in
another
there's a good sample walking through
this
if you go on the wiki under other topics
uh bridging to python there's a good
sample that shows exactly this about
a side process talking to a python
process
shuttling messages back and forth
maintaining the times as that happens so
you can still do joints and things like
that
that's a good example i should note
that if you actually are trying to do
communication between
two psi processes that can also be done
but i would
uh suggest using another system that we
just call remoting
that uses the inbuilt uh super efficient
serialization system
that psy has built into it and it
maintains the fidelity of the types and
things as these messages go back and
forth
and so that's that's kind of the
suggested way to do in a process
communication between
cyan apps if it's actually psi on both
ends
similarly uh working with ross is a very
common thing
and the solution is somewhat similar
ross is
a lot like psy in that it's also an
actor model with
loosely coupled little cohesive
components that communicate through
message passing
by default in ros the communication of
messages is over tcp
or udp using their own message
serialization protocol
and so we interface with ross by doing
the same kind of thing
we can serialize psi messages as ros
messages using that protocol
and we have a whole ross bridge built
for
joining a ross graph essentially you can
write side components
that can become nodes in a ros graph
they can talk to the master publish and
discover topics
discover other nodes negotiate
peer-to-peer connections
and serialize the messages back and
forth this is for
ros one actually the ros1 protocol
we may someday in the future release
something for the ross2 protocol
in in the meantime there are shims in
the ross ecosystem for
or shimming ross2 components to ross one
protocol
and again there are good examples in the
wiki again under other topics bridging
to ross
it shows a couple of good samples one of
them in particular just uses the ross
turtle
sim so you can just run that on a laptop
without having any hardware
which is nice and it has links to the
more in-depth documentation on how the
bridge itself actually works
so i hope that answers that question
back to you dan cool thanks thanks a lot
ashley
um yeah another question that
we sometimes that i saw in the in the
link here
was can the visualization tools that we
demonstrated be used
offline with previously collected data
streams
and certainly they can be used with data
you have collected with a psi
application but this is a request we've
gotten in the past about bringing your
own data that might be in different
formats
into the platform for cd intelligence
studio and being able to visualize
it and uh recently is actually in one of
the recent releases we have added like
that capability so there's a there's an
interface that you would have to
implement
basically create your own importer uh
that lets you bring
your data that might be stored in some
other format um
you know into the platform for serial
intelligence studio
um and do all the visualizations um we
actually implemented ourselves apart
from the support from
our own site stores created by psyapp
support for instance for opening wav
files
and just dragging them and bringing them
into size studio and
you can do more and this is again an
area where
uh we're trying to be an extensible
platform like
and we're hoping to get community
contributions
and uh build these capabilities more and
more and
interface and uh interrupt with more
data formats more ecosystems
i think hopefully that addressed that
question
there is another question about whether
it's possible to write your own
custom stream operators you know and
combine them with existing things like
the windowing operators and so on
um and um that's also certainly possible
uh it's definitely the way to to program
with sci off when you find yourself
having to write your your custom
processing operator psi
uh in the infrastructure provides a
pretty wide array of operators that work
over generic streams that let you do a
lot of basic operations over streams
including simple operations operations
that involve timeline synchronization
and so on like we discussed
uh but oftentimes you will need to write
your own custom specific
uh and it might be a simple operator
that takes a single input and produces a
single output
when you write that you can leverage
inside it other existing operators
there's a way to write these composite
components we call them
or it can be a complex composite
component
that has many inputs and many outputs
the idea is that
we would like to be able to reuse as
much as possible use the existing
components that you find in the
ecosystem and write new components um
that are specific to your application
where you don't find them
already and we again like with we've
mentioned before we hope to engage with
the community and we hope to grow this
ecosystem
over time uh with contributions so we
can better leverage um
each other's work
i'm not sure is there any other
questions or if we're uh
slowly getting towards the end of this q
a session
um sean and ashley have you seen some
other
question in the chat and you want to
talk a little bit about how the someone
asked about like the
how elbow angle was calculated and what
is that and
um i don't know yeah a little bit more
about that because that was with a
custom operator
basically yeah so so
and i i'm sorry you guys don't see look
this the sample
will be we'll post the sample shortly on
the github repo and you will be
we'll have a kind of a really nice walk
through that uh
walks you through that how exactly that
sample was built from the beginning to
an end and points to various other
um relevant pieces of documentation
um in the framework um but um
certainly for that elbow angle
computation is just uh
it's basically a custom stream operator
that takes in a body
and so it takes in a stream of bodies
essentially and produces a stream of
elbow angles
and essentially inside that operator you
just look at where the joints are for
the wrist
for the shoulder and for the elbow and
um
there are simple ways to do sort of 3d
angle computations
and compute that on a stream i think the
sample will will demonstrate it's uh it
illustrates you know relatively compact
like i said it's a couple of hundred
lines of code illustrated in a
relatively compact manner
the power of that you can get by quickly
combining a number of these uh stream
operators using a lot of existing ones
and writing your custom ones where you
need to um so i think as soon as that
probably hopefully by next week or
sometime you know soon that will be
we'll be able to push that up on the
repo um you guys can have a look
uh we're looking also i should say for
um you know
i mentioned this already i think in the
presentation for feedback
so wherever you you find we were not
able in the session to answer all the
questions but if you have specific
technical questions about the framework
uh please do not hesitate at all to file
issues on the on the github repo we're
happy to engage and
answer questions you might have around
this
i think that brings us close to time so
we'll probably uh stop here
thanks again uh everyone for attending
and well we really appreciate
your participation and interest in this
uh if you want to learn more there's a
list of
resources in the resource list on the
right of your screen
um it has pointers to the github site
and the blog post that we've recently
posted that gives a
high level overview of the framework and
as i mentioned before
we're hoping you'll engage with us via
github
in growing this to the next level thank
you so much